i want to share with you the story of
how i got to work today i submit to you
that my drive from my home to my office
used three forms of
intelligence the first intelligence
was human
intelligence
the intelligence there was the
intelligence done i needed to operate
the vehicle to turn the steering wheel
to check my mirrors
the second form of intelligence was
artificial
intelligence
once i got on the highway i turned on
the self-driving feature in my car
fancy
now the car stayed in its own lane kept
an appropriate distance from the vehicle
in front and maintained a proper speed
no input from me at all
when i got off of the highway i used a
third form of intelligence augmented
intelligence
augmented intelligence well that took
the form of all the driver assist
features in the vehicle things like
collision detection to alert me if i got
too close to the car in front and blind
spot avoidance to tell me if there was a
vehicle alongside me as i changed lanes
artificial intelligence well that is the
ability
for machines to perform tasks that
normally require human intelligence such
as reasoning
natural communication and problem
solving
it
basically replaces the need for a human
so
computers
are doing the work
us humans
not really needed
and the artificial intelligence performs
certain tasks and makes decisions and
it's incorporated into so many systems
today
now contrast that with augmented
intelligence
now this is where you have machines
and you have humans
both working together
and they're doing so to enhance each
other's efforts when completing tasks
augmented intelligence systems augment
our human abilities things like screen
readers for the blind voice driven
navigation or my
in-car collision avoidance system
they're all examples of augmented
intelligence at work they act on our
behalf in the physical world but in a
way that complements our own
capabilities
so
artificial
or augmented
which
form of intelligence will give us the
best results for a given problem well to
answer that let's create a strengths
matrix
so machines
versus humans
now one thing machines are great at is
ingesting large amounts of data
they can take in more data at a faster
rate than any human could and they also
don't get tired so they can just keep
going and going ingesting that data as
they go
machines are especially good at things
like repetitive tasks
and to do so in a way that is reliably
accurate
unlike my spelling of repetitive
so if you need to quickly analyze a lot
of data or do something over and over
again with no margin for error and then
specifically artificial intelligence is
really your best bet
now on the other hand us humans well we
have a few advantages too
we're very good at generalizing
information
we can take a single piece of data and
understand that the concept that it
represents we're also very good at
creativity
we can come up with ideas we can solve
problems and communicate our findings in
a way that well machines just can't and
we have emotional intelligence too
and that's a big benefit where we can
understand the reactions of others and
it's critical for tasks like customer
service or caregiving
now augmented intelligence is really a
sweet spot that combines all of these
human strengths with a bit of a helping
hand from our machine counterparts by
using ai to help us see and understand
the world in new ways we are able to do
things that would be impossible for us
humans on our own so
which form of intelligence is best
the answer is both and that's why i love
augmented intelligence it's how humans
will continue to thrive and lead in the
world
and get me to work safely
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe
thanks for watching